SUNIL VEMURI: Hello everyone.
My name is Sunil,
and this is Barnaby.
BARNABY JAMES: Hi.
SUNIL VEMURI: I'm a product
manager on the voice team.
Barnaby is a software
engineer, our technology leader
on the team.
We're here to talk to you about
what Google does with voice.
And one of the
interesting things
with this conference that,
at least, I've noticed
is so many of the
talks that came
prior to this mention Voice.
In the keynote yesterday,
you heard about Voice
in things like Brillo,
and even this morning, we
heard about how Voice is used in
Android Wear and Android Auto.
We want to use this
time as an opportunity
to tell you a little bit
more about what Google does
with Voice, its
capabilities, and also
mention a little bit about some
of the developer facing tools
that we have where you can
use Google's voice capability
to build products on this.
So as we're going
through this talk,
we'll give an overview
of what we can do.
But I'd love for you to keep
in mind one of the things
that you are building or how you
envision voice, and at the end,
either now or we have office
hours afterward as well,
we'd love to hear from you about
what are some of the things
that you would love to
do with Voice as well.
So with that, let
me get into it.
You might have
seen this already,
but this is some of
the things we can do.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Lift with your legs.
-It's not going to
fit up the stairs.
-What time does Goodwill close?
-Goodwill is open until 9:00 PM.
SUNIL VEMURI: Let's
start that over.
-Lift with your legs.
-It's not going to
fit up the stairs.
-What time does Goodwill close?
-Goodwill is open until 9:00 PM.
-Show me a moving
company nearby.
-Moving company
within six miles.
-How do I get to
3221 Carter Ave.?
-326 High Street.
-Here are your directions.
-When does my package arrive?
-Your most recent
order has shipped.
-Thank you.
-Setting new home address.
-Text Mom.
-I really like it here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNIL VEMURI: Set a
timer for 20 minutes.
GOOGLE NOW: OK, 20 minutes.
Starting.
SUNIL VEMURI: All right
that's how much time I have,
so that we have time for
questions at the end.
So let me back up a bit
before I talk about Voice.
Let's go back to our
original mission here.
We were founded to connect
users to information,
and it started with
the web searching.
You go to a desktop browser,
you type in a query,
and get to a
particular destination.
But nowadays, as we're seeing
more and more emerging devices,
and mobility is becoming
increasingly important,
the ways that users are
wanting to interface
with their technology
is changing.
And so this is why Voice is
an example of something that's
important to us, and why
it's important to Google
to invest in this area, to
provide new ways for people
to interface with their devices.
So we get a lot of traffic.
Huge amounts of traffic.
And the other thing
that's happening over time
is more and more of this
thing is becoming mobile.
Again, we started with
desktop, but there's
countries like US
and Japan where
the majority of the
traffic is coming in
on our mobile devices, and
that trend is continuing.
So again, more and
more reasons for us
to find ways to give users the
way to express what they want,
and use Google as the
conduit to get to places.
And in many times,
the destination
of these are things
that you built.
Websites that you have,
information you provide
services that you provide.
Having a much more
seamless experience
where a user wants
to ask for something,
and get to that destination,
and get to that answer,
is one of our goals.
So now let's talk a
little bit about Voice.
We did a study, a little
survey, a little while ago.
And we learned some things
about how people are using Voice
and who is using Voice.
So for example, one
of the things we found
is that teens are using
Voice more than adults.
So not only are we seeing more
and more applications embracing
Voice, we're seeing that
the younger generation are
using more and more Voice
in the types of things
that they're doing
with technology.
So when we drill into this, what
are people doing with Voice?
So we see a little
bit of difference
between teens and adults.
Asking for directions is common.
But teens are using it to
help with their homework.
I know my children ask their
technology for questions,
like who is the president
at a particular time,
or things like that.
So we're seeing more and
more examples of the younger
generation using this.
For messaging, however, adults
are using Voice a little bit
more.
So there are a
variety of ways where
we see Voice is increasingly
used for a number of purposes,
and also the difference
between the ages.
So when are people
using Voice search?
There a number of
interesting things
here about where this is taking
place and some differences
between teens and adults, also.
But the one thing here that
kind of stood out to us
is this thing in the bathroom.
OK.
So we don't know why exactly,
and I've asked some people why.
If any of you have
ideas about this,
if you're using voice
technologies-- doesn't have
to be ours-- in
the bathroom, I'd
love to hear a little
bit more about it.
Yeah you have a question?
AUDIENCE: How do you know
they're in the bathroom?
SUNIL VEMURI: That's
a great question,
and I have a very
un-creepy answer to this.
We ask them.
So hopefully I'm not
violating any confidentiality
saying we do not have
a technology that
detects when people are
in about the bathroom.
I'm sorry could you
repeat the question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
SUNIL VEMURI: You know, we're
going to repeat and update
this survey.
I'll make sure we come up
with some way of metricing
the honesty on this one.
But yes, the
bathroom seems to be
an important place for Voice.
So here's where we have
the idea section here.
What do people want
to use Voice for?
Pizza, find the remote,
and find the keys.
So this might give some
interesting product
ideas for any of you,
which is the ability
to order a pizza while
you're in the bathroom.
So this is the direction Voice
may be going, I don't know.
But hopefully it'll inspire
some great minds out there.
And hopefully by the
end of this talk,
you'll see we have
some of the tools
necessary to build
some of these things.
And hopefully maybe
somebody in this audience
will take up one of
these tasks of building
a product like this.
So that's how people
are using Voice.
Now let me pause for a moment
here and talk about something
that we at Google have built
out over the years that helped
and able some of this.
And this is what's called
the Knowledge Graph.
Now this technology
isn't just for Voice.
It's applied for a number
of different projects
within Google, but voice is
one of the beneficiaries of it.
So what is the Knowledge Graph?
This is a technology that
has information about things
and the relationships
between things.
So, for example, we know the
Eiffel Tower is a building.
It's a structure.
And there are other
structures that might
be related to the Eiffel Tower.
The Eiffel tower
has some properties,
like its height
and its location.
So knowing that the
Eiffel Tower isn't just
a sequence of characters,
but is a thing,
and it has these
other properties,
helps us figure out when
we hear a query, what
is the intent of it and
what is the relationship
of that piece of information
to other things out there.
So let me give you
an example that
illustrates what the benefit
of Knowledge Graph is,
and how it connects to Voice.
Suppose I gave this query.
Who wrote the Declaration
of Independence?
Well, hopefully,
it's not too unknown.
It's Thomas Jefferson.
He wrote the Declaration
of Independence,
among others by the way.
Now, a voice query like this.
How old was he when he died?
And I didn't say how old was
Thomas Jefferson when he died,
how old was he when he died.
Well if we did something
like this, what would we get?
Thomas Jefferson
died when he was 83.
And then we see these
other bits of information,
for example, the presidents.
So this is where the
Knowledge Graph came in.
It knew that Thomas
Jefferson was a president,
there's some metadata
information about him,
and there's a relationship
to these other people that
are listed here, including
Ben Franklin, who
was not a president here.
So those relationships are
encoded within the Knowledge
Graph.
OK.
So now let's continue
this a little bit.
On what day did he die?
So does anybody know what
date Thomas Jefferson died?
Or where I'm going with this?
July 4, there we go.
So July 4, 1826.
That's when Thomas
Jefferson died.
And again, I didn't say what
David Thomas Jefferson die.
What day did he die?
And this gets into how people
want to speak naturally.
When we speak, we
don't reformulate
every detail of every
query, and resolve
all the pronouns, et cetera.
We want to be able
to speak naturally.
And the Google Engine is
capable of these things.
Now, these may be things you
haven't tried as much as some
of your other queries, but
that capability is there.
And I wanted to illustrate
this is the kind of engine
that we are working with.
And the world-class
capability that's
underlying some of
our technology here.
OK.
Well, I've got another
trivia bit for you.
How about John Adams?
Anybody know this?
AUDIENCE: Same day.
SUNIL VEMURI: Same day.
Exactly.
Thomas Jefferson and John Adams
died exactly the same day.
July 4.
So interesting bit
of trivia here,
that may be the one thing
you take away from this,
I hope it's not.
But as many of you who
have done presentations
knows, sometimes
that's the way it goes.
OK.
So that is what
the Knowledge Graph
gave as part of this thing,
as part of our underlying
technology here.
Let me take a moment to
say a little bit more
about our speech
capabilities here.
Now, at Iowa this year,
Sundar Pachai, our CEO,
gave some some statistics about
how our speech recognition
technology has improved.
So the word error rate--
one of the metrics
we use to determine how
well a speech recognition
engine works, like
how many errors you
get per, say, 100 words--
has improved from 20% percent
to 8%.
At the time of Iowa,
that's what we reported.
At that level, now we're
getting into a technology
that can really be
used in a greater
number of circumstances.
If any of you who have either
played in the speech field
or worked in the speech
field, even decades ago,
you know it was relegated
to certain niche areas.
Or for certain fun things,
you can get a little program
on your computer, talk
to it a little bit,
but it was still hard to use.
Nowadays, with this
level of performance,
we can really build valuable
products out of this.
And that's another area that
Google has invested a lot in.
But it's not just
our word error rate
that's improved over the years.
We've also increased the number
of languages that we support.
Over 20 languages, in fact,
we can handle that speech
at this point.
So it's becoming much
more widely accessible.
Back in the day, you'd have to
do training of these things.
That isn't the case anymore.
There have been lots of
advancements in speech,
and now it's at the time
where you can actually build
valuable products off of it.
Now, in a moment
Barnaby is going
to be talking a little bit
about our developer program,
and our APIs, and
how those work,
so you can get a sense as
to how people can build off
of these things, and
examples of developers
who have built some things.
Before we do that,
let me just give you
a last little bit of overview
of how some of this works.
So typically, they speak
into the Google microphone.
And in this case, it's
on an Android phone.
They speak into that, we
do the speech to text.
We also have a natural language
processing capability that
interprets what that query was.
What does it mean?
What is the user trying to do?
And we use the Knowledge Graph
to help figure out and resolve
these questions of what are
the things that the users are
asking for.
And in some cases, this
thing goes back to Google,
and we show results.
Like in the case of the
Thomas Jefferson example,
that was Google that
providing the answer.
But now, what if
you have the answer?
Or your service is the one
that can produce a result here?
This is the part this is
the next part of the talk
that we're getting into.
How do you inform Google
about your capabilities
so that you can be the
one that gives the answer?
I want to give one
last bit here before I
pass the mic for a while.
Now, there is speech recognition
and there's the interpretation
of the speech.
We've had the Android
speech recognition
API for some time now.
And what this does is,
on an Android device,
you start the speech
recognizer, and then you
say just report back
to me what was said.
Here, that's essentially
like a transcript.
Here are the words
that the user says.
It says little about
the interpretation
of what those words
or what should be done
as a result of those words.
So this is the first
API that's been around.
And over the past
year or so, we've
been introducing new APIs that
allowed it to do much more.
Let me pass it to Barnaby.
BARNABY JAMES: Hi.
So we've been steadily
adding voice action APIs that
let you extend
what the system is
able to do by completing the
actions inside of your Android
apps.
So this kind of breaks down
into three different areas.
System actions, custom actions,
and the voice interaction API.
I'll be talking about all three.
So System Voice
Actions are a sort
of standard set of common
cases of things that people
want to do with their phones.
And Google defines the
grammars and then defines
an API that we will call out
to your app to let you actually
complete the action.
Here's an example of
someone playing music,
but it could be things
like setting alarms
or other common use cases.
Here's a set of
examples, there's
actually more than this, but
fitness, media, communications,
messaging, things like
that, search within an app.
So how do you
implement one of these?
For some cases, it's
actually really, really easy.
In-app search is
one where we try
to make it as easy as possible.
If you use the
Android search widget,
you pretty much just have to add
that one line, or four lines,
I guess, to your
activity intent filter
that says I can handle the
special kind of search that
comes from the Android
Google search assistant.
And when you say, OK, Google,
search for hotels in Maui
on TripAdvisor, we do all the
natural language understanding,
and different ways you
may phrase that query,
and express it as an action that
you want to take semantically,
and then a set of parameters,
in this case, a query hotels
in Maui, and the app that we're
going to target that intent to.
Similarly, if you
say, "play music,"
maybe say, "play
classical music,"
maybe say "play a
specific song or artist,"
natural language
understanding figures out
what specific artist it was, no
matter how the user phrases it.
And you get this
common command that
expresses what the
user's intention was,
and then a set of extras that
describe more the parameters.
So in this case, it's a
genre, it's classical,
and the query was
classical music.
If it was an artist,
we would have
a way of telling you
the specific song
or a specific artist that
was actually referring to.
But sometimes, the
common use cases
are not going to cover what
you want to do in your app.
You may have something that's
special to your app, where
the way that you
want to say it is
going to be specific to your
application terminology.
So we started this program
called Custom Voice Actions,
in which you can work with
Google to define actions that
are available in your specific
app and nobody else's.
So here is an example.
Show me restaurants
nearby on TripAdvisor.
And the way this
works is you provide
us examples of the action
that you want to do.
So I might say, "start
my car," but there's
multiple different
parameter types.
Google Car, driver-less
cars, self driving car.
And then we use the
Google natural language
understanding to generalize
ways that people might say that.
So "please start my car,"
"warm up my Google car,"
or "start the driver-less
car," and make
it a more general
thing that's going
to be able to
trigger in more cases
than if we just use the one
example that you give us.
So more than 1,000
apps have implemented
these kind of Voice Actions,
from media to in-app search,
and we recently
did an integration
with a bunch of messaging apps.
So the messages
are actually sent
in WhatsApp versus just
sending it through SMS.
OK.
So in Android M, we have a new
API called voice interaction
API.
And the idea here is, everything
I've talked about thus
far just gets you into your
app, and at that point,
the voice experience stops
from your perspective.
So we go into your
app, but you don't
have any way of interacting with
the users through their voice.
In a lot of cases, you're either
going to complete the action,
or you're just going to show a
touch UI that you're expecting
the user to interact with.
So the voice
interaction API lets
you know that the action was
triggered by the user's voice,
ask back and forth questions to
clarify what it was they meant,
and then tell the user what
it was they actually did.
And you're able to do all
of this with the screen off.
So to follow on to
Bill's the example.
We've all been there.
You're in the
bathtub, and you want
to turn on the
alarm in your house.
So in Custom Voice
Actions, you're
able to trigger that intent.
But maybe you have
multiple modes
you can trigger in your house.
For example, there's away
mode where you're actually
not at home, but
you're in the bathtub
so you don't want it to turn
on the internal sensors, just
the external sensors.
So I need to ask a
question to do that.
The Scout app implements
this activity,
but if you are triggering
it as a voice interaction,
you're able to ask the
question, "what mode of alarm
do you want to set?"
And then there's a
bunch of options,
and they set away mode.
Now it can tell us,
OK, I'm arming away.
And so now even if you
can't see your phone,
you know that it actually
completed that action for you.
So let's see a demo on this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Please select
which mode to arm.
Which mode?
SUNIL VEMURI: I'm
going to reset.
-Away.
Turn on Scout alarm.
-Please select which mode.
Which mode?
-Away.
-Arming away.
[END PLAYBACK]
SUNIL VEMURI: So
in that case, you
were in the scout alarm
app, and you're actually
having dialogue with the user.
And it pretty much just looked
like the Scout alarm app,
but there's this plate at the
bottom called the voice plate.
So the idea is the assistant
and your application
are sort of sharing the screen.
The bit at the bottom, where
this microphone appears,
is where the Google assistant
is able to do dialogue and show
the user what the speech
recognition results are.
For the top part of it, it's
actually your application
running as it normally
would, and you're
able to use this to
now control the UI
through your voice
versus just doing it
through touch interaction.
So how did this work?
Is that a lot of work?
Mostly not.
So you start with
a voice activity,
or maybe, in the Scout example,
it's actually just the activity
that a normal app uses, and
they added the voice experience
onto it.
So you add this category
to your intent filter
that says, "hey, if I'm
triggered by voice, then
we'll trigger you
in some special way,
and you advertise that
you're able to handle
this kind of interaction.
Then you have a sort of
standard Android activity.
You make this call to
isVoiceInteractionRoot
that tells you whether or
not it's a voice interaction.
If it is, you run it in
a slightly different way.
Maybe if it's not, you run it as
just a regular touch activity.
So what kind of
questions can I ask?
This is a confirmation question.
For example, "are you sure
you want to do this?",
which is a pretty common case.
If it's something that maybe we
misinterpreted what they said,
or the speech recognition
was slightly off
you would make sure we're
going to actually do this.
So you get this
voice interaction
and you say, "I want to make
a new confirmation question.
Are you sure."
And then you specify what should
happen if they are, in fact,
sure.
This flag will say whether
it was confirmed or not.
Remember, you don't have to
do the speech recognition.
You don't have to do the
natural language understanding.
So we'll understand all
the sort of common ways
people say, "are you sure?"
Yes.
OK.
Make it so all these things will
actually cause it to trigger.
Another common thing that
people will want to do
is pick an option.
This is what the Scout app did.
So say we want to
pick what kind of pet
you want to use for something.
So you specify all
of the options.
You give dog, cats,
fish, and maybe
you can specify synonyms
on these as well.
We'll do some amount of
matching to the options of what
the user said to
actually make sure
that we pick one of the
options that are available,
but it's really ambiguous
will re-prompt the user
and say, "we're not sure
what you meant in that case."
Then you say "what kind of pet?"
is the question I want to ask.
And these are the options
that I want to use.
And then, finally, it
says what happens when
it picks one of those options.
And that's when you
implement the code to say,
OK, a pet was selected.
This is probably almost
exactly the same code
as if somebody touched that
option in the list view
with their finger.
So we talked about pick option
requests and confirmation
requests.
Picking from a list or
confirming an action.
There's also another thing
available in the API called
command requests.
This is a extension
that lets us add
different kinds of questions.
So the idea is we'll
grow the set of questions
you can ask over time.
Things like, maybe, ask for
a date, or pick a location.
Something like that.
And then there's
a set of options
here which you would
call informing the user.
So when you complete something
in the Scout app, it told us
"yes, I set the
alarm to away mode,"
you want to tell
the user by voice,
because they started interaction
with voice, that "yes, I
was actually able
to complete that,"
so they know that
it's actually done.
If you're just silent
and nothing happens,
how is the user going
to know what happened?
And then, even more
important, if you're not
able to complete the action,
tell the user why it is.
Maybe you're offline and
you're not able to complete it.
Maybe you don't have
the account set up.
But we want the user to know
that this didn't happen,
and now I understand why.
And you could ask
follow-up questions,
but maybe it's
something where they're
going to have to actually
touch the screen to do.
So again, just to review,
these are the three kinds
of interactions you have.
System actions for common
things, custom actions where
we let you define the grammar,
and then voice interaction
lets you keep that conversation
going into your app.
OK.
So I think we have some
time for questions,
because the beeper
just went off.
And just to
reiterate, we're going
to doing office hours at 2:30
in the costume shop, which
I didn't know where this
was so I'll tell you.
If you go out the
front of the building,
and you turn right on Market
Street, there's a vacant lot.
In the building
right next to that
is the costume shop,
where they have code labs
and we'll be doing office hours.
SUNIL VEMURI: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So the
Google speech engine
is able to resolve [INAUDIBLE]
onthology granularity
[INAUDIBLE].
For example, when I say find me
a driver-less car versus find
me a self-driving
car, there are two--
BARNABY JAMES:
There are synonyms.
AUDIENCE: A car that
doesn't require a driver.
Should I could that myself?
SUNIL VEMURI: So
the question was,
looking back to
the example, will
Google be able to,
I believe, determine
the self-driving car
and a driver-less car
are the same thing and
automatically figure
all that out?
In the example we
gave there, we showed
that the developer provides
the various common ways
of describing the same concept.
Now, in some cases, Google
can figure out alternate ways
of saying those things.
Developers won't have a lot
of transparency into knowing
what exactly those are.
So in many cases, we ask
people to just give us
some of the common
examples that make sense
as synonymous ways of
saying the same thing,
and then it's a better
product for the end users
if that's the case.
I think I saw a
question over there.
AUDIENCE: How does Google
filter out extraneous words?
So for example, I have a
friend that really, really
enjoys testing Google.
He's like, OK, Google,
please plan me this.
Thank you very much.
I love you.
Like he gives it a
very long string.
How does it actually filter
out and calculate what--
SUNIL VEMURI: OK so the
question is, how do we
make Google accommodate
the politeness of our users
and verbosity.
So the specific techniques
is beyond the scope
of what I have time to cover,
and I probably can't describe
all the techniques anyway.
I can say, yes, there
are capabilities.
We gave an example
where using the word
please and some other
niceties are adding articles.
Those are some of the things
that are common there.
Now, if your friend has run
into some cool examples where
we're failing, let us know.
We want to hear
about this stuff.
Because that's what
people do, right?
It should have
the right outcome.
think I saw a
question there next.
AUDIENCE: Is this still
invitation only program?
Or can anyone develop
[INAUDIBLE] actions?
SUNIL VEMURI: So the question
was, is this an invitation only
program?
What you saw there, Barnaby
outlined three APIs.
System actions, custom
actions, voice interaction API.
System actions are totally
open, voice interaction API
is completely open.
These are documented
publicly on our website.
Custom actions, that is
something where, right now,
our waiting list is a bit long.
And we've gotten
a lot of requests.
So if you want to
do custom actions,
please come talk to
me afterward and then
we can get you on the
wait list for this.
OK over here.
BARNABY JAMES: Last
question, I think.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
anything in place
to help people who are building
endangered language translators
and speech solutions?
Because we don't have
speech handlers for them.
[INAUDIBLE]
SUNIL VEMURI: OK.
So do we have anything to help
with endangered languages?
So our team doesn't work
on that specific thing.
But maybe that's something
you can come talk
to us about at office hours.
I'd love to learn
a little bit more
about what you're looking for.
And even if our
team can't help you,
then we can try to redirect the
question to the right place.
Are we out of time?
Yes, we're out of time.
We have office hours
at the costume shop.
We'll be there
for the next hour.
I know lots of you
have questions.
Please come there, we'll be
happy to answer your questions
there.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]